hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing defense of Ramiz of who the heck
is that
Ramiz off okay so um we have them well
sir call again the orangutan be 45 b5
okay
oh that's really hard okay let's just
play quickly I mean what that the main
one of the main points of playing such
an opening with widest you're irritated
simply with black because I mean it is
not really good but you try to
completely review it and spend time and
so on instead of just playing like
normal moves that gives you a good game
and then then you can get on get on with
things really no need to spend lots of
time okay now the bishop won't be forum
sucks
so let's retreat it and f4 is ought to
oughta move yeah but is it is it bad you
know
I don't know
it looks really hot hmm
but there is no clear way to refute it
before is something that I would be
really interested in playing but not too
easy to do and again I'm taking far too
much time here for this for this stuff
yeah this is an interesting idea but you
very I mean as I spotted the idea
immediately and I could have played it
in me at Lane but it didn't which is sir
not so great okay my idea was officially
at five now but then he's good 94
you
yeah now and I takes it to us on the
cards oops
officially for I missed actually I
absolutely missed that opportunity for
him
no I didn't see that one coming yeah
that's that's a bit of a that is a real
nuisance that I miss dad
you
very very real opening very weird game
let's see him now if I play I cannot
really play
my night
94 94 mm unfortunately
and the bishop is also a little bit
stay well so I'm going to get away
attacking d2 as well is it such an odd
position many things are kind of kind of
wrong here
both sides I've got some liabilities
here
you
we'll see
I can take the one what nan Bishop f6 m
let's play Bishop f6 him otherwise 94
yeah let's do it I have to speed up a
little bit I mean this is increment but
still I cannot play 94 of this name made
on g7 hmm missing too many too many
simple tactic sim
Knight h5 I've got Queen d2 to his base
back rank is very weak
like Queen diem 1f Queen takes D to
you
okay wow what they were to wiki game
when Queen age so I could be something
cannot calculator just have to play
threatening rookie one
you
a g3 looks very normal here
you
okay - I don't know what that threatens
okay anyway
[Music]
and threatening queen h3 bit
we have to figure this out
I don't know how he defends Queen h3
really I don't see it at the moment
three Queen age three still works
did he do we should be too had threatens
absolutely nothing
you
yeah that was tough that was really
tough super nerd
position yeah b5 so a 6b should be -
maybe it's I don't know maybe it's
better to not I mean but there must be
okay I'm winning lots of Tempe and I
think the position is definitely fine
you probably cannot expect more than
like being slightly better with black
even after such a bad opening but Tim
yeah okay so a 3d 5 is 3 I try to play
quickly the engine wants to play Knight
a 7 no sorry I won't do that
it came so that's all kind of normal we
should be 6 that was a bit offside I
played f4 f4 is an odd move I mean maybe
he was actually worried that I could
sacrifice you after castling it is
possible that this works it's always
tough to figure out he has to go to g3
and now watch yeah Queen d6 or Queen g5
hmm tough the engine gives equal via 0
no impossible impossible to analyze like
now quickly so we went f4 and I went
with this night before idea which is
probably not great the the engine wants
to play Bishop e7
one night is okay my idea here was I
thought like okay maybe c3 is ridiculous
anyway when after c3 at Bishop to d7 I
wanted to play this little trick because
this is obviously very nice and he has
no good reply now so it was a bit of a
trap but c3 is probably ridiculous
anyway okay play played castling plate
c6
Bishop f5 and I was
I thought that was a neat idea but maybe
it is just not I actually is simply
simply missed that he has Bishop a4
I was simply overlooking that I thought
I'm just fine now and win c2 and be be
great yeah well I didn't see that move I
just didn't see it it seems that I
should play something slow like Bishop
d7 and actually threaten that and that
act that looks very good at that looks
good okay so I missed that one
and now it was just extremely murky and
probably an f5 is very good for white
yeah that shows us that this is very
vulnerable this configuration with the
Queen coming here and Bishop on that
very strong diagonal yeah that's it
yeah it's Academy once you see it you
know all that still that's okay white
White's why don't we loop that and now
okay deform just wanted to be as active
as possible yeah I was very surprised
that he just didn't take it I mean it
looks so normal
take the strong bishop of the board and
and that must be good for why am i am
active but it's not nothing good okay
rook e8 Queen g3 i preserved that bishop
and now he played 91 therefore the
shocking move somehow
and I can't take on the two immediately
which I absolutely did not spot no
this and now Quincy three is losing her
yeah it loses straightaway
he has to play Queen to f3 after which I
wanted to take on the two but that seems
to be impossible
that is the refutation
recover z1f yeah it's kind of not so
difficult but now 93 was winning oh but
Queen h4 is also winning okay so my move
is fine and I could have gone to age
three immediately but this is this is
mate it's a mate I didn't see it off was
that it is a force made but exactly this
is a mate cannot defend against it this
is the key point I have to need this
yeah
and now threatening mate here and if you
take such a meeting like that yeah and
we should be too as force to me yeah not
helping but there is no no safe okay
guys thanks for watching